the Joe Rogan experience see if you can
find this conversation Jamie that there
it's so and it's it says they're joking
but it also has a question that says out
there joke
no but that's mediate says there J right
yeah every other website is not saying
they're joking it doesn't sound like
they're joking I think they're trying to
come up with some sort of a cover for it
but let's let's play what what he said
it's John Roberts who is a correspondent
for Fox and then who is the other guy
the other guy who works for the New York
Times Doug mills he's a photographer
Doug okay so now let's it says
apparently joking I doesn't sound like
you're joking play play what it says
because John let me explain it here John
Roberts comes in and it's gonna play an
ad before this Jamie so kill the volume
John Roberts comes in and when he comes
in he's not wearing a mask and he tells
the other gentleman you could take the
mask off and he tells them about this la
study go ahead play it
USC
but they really believe that if they're
anywhere across 220 1404 2,000 people
who were in fact really yeah so that
makes a study
so it suggests vacation calendars
I was a host so here's here's what's
weird about that one that guy says well
we've all been vaccinated here anyway
right now maybe he was joking maybe he's
got a weird sense of humor long joke
it's a weird joke weird yeah now they
have done some trial vaccines there are
some vaccines that are in trial there
was a woman in Seattle she was the first
person to get tested and I sent this
stuff to Matt Staggs earlier today and
he sent something to me there there have
been several different there's 70
coronavirus vaccines right now that are
under development with three in human
trials okay so there there have been
some things going on right now and the
first person treated with the corona
virus is in Seattle there's an article
about that what she's talking about
getting tested but yeah this this guy
saying we've all been vaccinated like I
don't know what that means it's hard to
tell people people have weird senses of
humor right like if you listen to comics
right and you took some of the [ __ ] that
we say we say ridiculous [ __ ] all the
time and we get used to it right maybe
they say ridiculous [ __ ] too I think so
dealing with right now right but the
other guy coming in saying you don't
have to wear a mask so Roberts comes in
with no mask on yeah it says you don't
need a mask to take the mask off yeah
well that study's weird man
because okay maybe maybe I believe the
mortality rate is correct I believe that
it's way less deadly than they thought
it was but they had to prepare for
something that they thought was gonna be
real deadly because it's real deadly in
Italy so but the question is like
there's so many questions why is it so
deadly in Italy is it because they're
older people is it because they smoke
why is it so deadly to New York City
like is it because they're stack
on top of each other is it definitely
definitely definitely that
[Applause]